coignières une commune de moins de 4500
habitants avec une double identité
urbaine et rurale
c'est dans cette optique que la ville
souhaite intégrer le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
coignières pourrait avoir un statut de
ville porte en 2023 intégrer le pnr
permettrait de valoriser son patrimoine
et notamment son église ainsi que ces
espaces naturels autre enjeu la
destruction du silo aux abords de la
résidence des acacias du centre
commercial le silo servait de parking
mais il a été muré par le bailleur en
2012 les voitures ne pouvaient plus y
garer conséquence le quartier manque de
places de stationnement la structure
devrait être démolie dans les prochains
mois pour aménager un parking et un
square de zones commerciales sont
également repenser les portes de
chevreux et le forum jb le secteur est
au coeur d'une étude globale de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour redynamiser cette zone
commerciale avec celle de paris ouest à
maurepas une zone commerciale traverser
notamment par la nationale 10 comme pour
la commune de trappes lax coupe la ville
en deux
l'affection devrait être menée sur la
requalification une rénovation du
carrefour de la malmö données notamment
à l'étude et concernera coignières la
verrière et mon repas enfin coignières
intégré 50 ans yves hinant 2016 à doit
aujourd'hui imaginer ces futures
collaborations avec les communes de
cette agglomération
ces dernières années la ville a
abandonné son projet de fusion avec
maurepas en 2018 coignard également mis
fin à la police municipale avec maurepas
après un an d'existence et la commune
n'a pas intégré le projet de centre
aqualudique avec maurepas elancourt